thank you
so much everyone for coming i was i was
worried i wouldn't have a seat with
everyone outside
thank you for showing up um
so this talk is going to be um
basically a high level overview of some
of the things that you're going to bump
into
when you're doing something with rust
and the linux kernels so
rust is going to give you a lot of
benefits as a low-level language
and it doesn't work quite out of the box
so we're going to go over
some of the gotchas that come about when
you're trying to make this happen
so essentially we're going to first talk
about
what is rust and why are we using it so
that's a big question that comes up a
lot when people discuss a new language
it there are a lot of people that you
know kind of need to be sold first on
its usefulness so we'll go over that a
little bit
then we're going to do a demo of my
kernel module and
then we'll talk about leveraging
existing kernel tools
for um actually building rust and
last we'll talk about the most
interesting part which is some rust
specific gotchas
so things that you might not expect to
bump into
at a lower level and sort of how we can
get around that
so first off what is rust and why are we
using it
the reason for rust tends to be
that it's a highly systems oriented
programming language it's very high
performance
despite it being a relatively new
language started around
2010 then it's actually made a lot of
headway in that time
and so we got some really nice benefits
like no garbage collection or manual
memory management and the allocations
and de-allocations really are handled by
the compiler for you
it has a robust type system that is
going to allow you
to use unsafe to kind of opt out of
those stricter security checks
and it's llvm based so it's going to
give you a lot of those really nice
optimizations
all of that together with kind of the
existing ecosystem
of out-of-the-box documentation and
built-in testing capabilities
kind of make it a really attractive
option for a lot of people
so we'll talk a little bit about the
safety guarantees
so rust is strongly typed so it's able
to do
some pretty intense type validation for
you
it has ownership validation which at a
high level
is what scope owns this data
at what time it's also able to do
mutability validation which essentially
says
when we have references which of these
references can mutate at a given time
and together these provide some pretty
attractive guarantees
so we're going to have memory safety so
no dangling pointers and safe rust
we have data race safety so we can't
access
data from two locations at any one time
and for write access and
these guarantees can all be overridden
with the unsafe keyword
so who here is familiar with what an avi
is raise of hands and who here needs a
review
we can go through this okay thank you
so um an abi at a high level
is going to essentially be a standard of
generated assembly that
basically guarantees that when you link
two things together that it will be
compatible
so this includes things like consistent
assembly instructions
data type sizes and alignment and it's
also going to be
calling conventions and register usage
so
um this is very important when it comes
down to interoperability between
languages
so a lot of times we'll have
interoperability between new languages
and c
kind of plagued by a lot of things like
you know driving the runtime and garbage
collector
from c we'll have data type conversions
that get pretty painful
um we'll have to just explicitly write
some bindings and see
and kind of link that into our new
language
or sometimes we even have to write
assembly and
you know a lot of people like to avoid
that so
russ's approach is that you can um
explicitly coerce
um functions to really um
stick to the c abi at compile time
and so we get some major benefits from
this
one of the things that we're going to
get is that
we can link directly with c and this is
pretty simple
compared to some of the other approaches
i outlined
um rust actually is going to
natively support um in its build system
linking c directly into the rest program
so
even the build system works with it
pretty simply
and we really don't need any assembly
for this whole process so
this overall is going to make rust a
very good candidate
for kernel development um anything that
we are not able to offload to rust we're
able to still do and see
so things like the c preprocessor
are really going to need to be done in c
there's no kind of type safe way to
represent that and
particularly if we're accessing data
fields
in a struct that is kind of littered
with if deaths
then at that point we are really going
to want to offload that to c as well
so we'll talk a little bit about the
type system too rest is strongly typed
so we're going to get validation of data
types passed into functions
and validation of pass by reference
versus pass by value
but both of those things can already be
done by c
so what else does it kind of give us
that
we don't get in c and some of these
things are going to be things like
explicit conversions only so we're never
going to have
sort of a wiggly kind of type casting
system
we actually have to explicitly say how
we're going to convert from one type to
another and so this really avoids some
undefined behavior that could pop up
we're going to have type parameters or
generics as they're known in a lot of
other languages
this is also validated and supported by
the compiler
we have mutability checks and what this
is going to do for us is we have two
rules
so we can either have one mutable
reference
and no immutable references um to
prevent
sort of read write corruption or we can
have
as many immutable references as we want
um and no mutable references so you can
kind of think of it like a read write
lock at the compiler level
um ownership we use move semantics
and so basically mutable
and immutable references can be passed
into functions
but essentially that does not that does
not constitute a move
um own data types will be
moved when they're passed into a
function and they cannot be used in the
original scope
after they have been moved these
guarantee memory safety and data race
safety kind of as we talked about before
so when it comes to performance we often
get into
a lot of kind of nitty-gritty number
related details and people always want
to know which is faster c
or rest and i'm going to kind of
sidestep all of that because
we're instead going to go over some
non-controversial points
so um rust is going to produce native
binaries
um there is no garbage collection or vms
so essentially
we're going to get some performance
boost from that um
rust uses llvm as a back end so
anything that clang has in terms of
optimizations
those are also available to rust um
rust is also going to use in
intermediate representation
and what this allows us to do is rust
specific optimizations
so that happens before we compile it
down to llvm
so when we're actually writing sort of
more performance critical code
that really relies on some kind of
unsafe pointer magic
then rust also provides unsafe
capabilities to drop down to that level
and really do what we need to do we can
kind of think of rust as
generally in the same performance class
as
c and c plus plus
and rest unsafe keyword which we
mentioned in the last slide
is going to allow us to do a few things
we can dereference raw pointers we can
call code that has been marked as unsafe
and we can access or modify mutable
static variables so
um these these kinds of operations are
often needed when we're doing some sort
of
ffi and so this unsafe keyword is really
kind of crucial for
um building c into the actual nuts and
bolts of the language
so now we're going to have a little demo
of my
kernel module so um
the kernel module itself is pretty silly
but it does do some really important
things
so it's going to do some char device
creation
using the kernel api for that it has
some mutex locking in there
it's going to even be able to print out
to the kernel logs
and it even does some buffer operations
that are
actually marked as safe and sort of
encode the length in the buffers
so we don't really have to worry about
buffer overflows here
so it's really just going to create an
animation that when you cat
the device node then what it's going to
do is it's going to display an animation
so first i'll give you
kind of the steps if you're looking to
reproduce this on your own machine
and now we'll go through it
so here is my project directory
is that good okay
so we're just going to run make it's
going to build this kernel module
we're going to insert
the module
and now we're going to check the logs
for the major and minor number
and slash dev slash
parrot here we go
[Applause]
so what does this kernel module do
we party hard
so how did i do this well
i leveraged actually a lot of existing
tooling
for the kernel so we have here a list of
basically all of the tools you'll need
for this
um but the most important one really is
cable
because that is the native system for
the kernel builds and so we're actually
able to leverage that because of rust
cabi compatibility to actually offload a
lot of this
so what changes well we're going to
um have to do something a little bit
more manageable
manual to basically create
our object files and we'll have to do
a few function declaration level changes
on the rest side and the way the kernel
api methods are handled on the rest side
will also have to change
so k build really is going to be the
easiest way to accomplish this task
because um it's makefile based and
accepts cabi compatible object files
and it's also you know going to be
semi-shell based
so we're able to call into different
tools that we need in the rust ecosystem
um we will need to download some devel
packages
um and while the cable documentation is
pretty dense
usually it will give you everything you
could possibly need to know
for something like this one note
that you should definitely put a
bookmark in
is that it's going to ignore static
libraries
so this actually comes into play later
um on as for rust side changes we'll
have to make two specific
changes that are really important here
one is going to be an attribute that we
attach to the functions for entry points
that is no mangle um and one
is going to be just declaring this as
compatible with the cabi
as an extern function um
overall the rule is that we should keep
everything
compatible with the cabi so for example
we're going to want to use
pointers instead of references and
similar kind of um cabi compatible
data types that map directly to rust
data types but have a little bit
less information encoded
so no mangle is really important because
by default c
is going to assign a label that
essentially
just kind of maps from this entry point
in the kernel to this label right here
so it's really a one-to-one correlation
um rust is actually going to mangle the
symbols
so we have a nip module and it's going
to
take it out of the global namespace by
mangling it as we see right here
the solution is that on kernel entry
points we just
attach no mangle to the top of this
function
and we're going to get the unmangled
symbol
um when we actually talk about extern c
function declarations then
um one note is that this is not going to
validate that everything you have done
is cabi compliant so there is some work
that you have to do to make sure you're
doing everything correctly
however this is because um not
everything
that is in rust is actually compatible
with the cabi
you can force it to become that way but
it's not going to be that way by default
and this should be relatively intuitive
because
ultimately we're representing things
that are just not representable in the
the c type system
so um data types really must conform to
the c abi
so we'll have integer primitives um that
are acceptable
anything in the lib secret and pointers
to
any of those acceptable types we can
also mark
structs as specifically cabi compatible
and this is going to exclude a lot of
things like
vectors and slices and a lot of other
data types that we just can't use
so slices will not work because they
encode length
and pointers do not um references
also encode additional information that
pointers do not
we're not going to be able to use u128s
because c
does not support those at the cabi level
and um we're also going to have to mark
those structs
as explicitly cabi compatible because of
memory optimizations that rust will do
for us
so we should talk a little bit about
libcore because this
is going to be everything that we need
from in terms of
basically a standard library so you can
think of lib4
as the standard library for
embedded or systems work that's
basically going to allow you to define
your own allocation
and do a little bit lower level things
like that
um that essentially um
the standard library itself is going to
um
take for granted so we're going to need
to
include this somehow in our build so
it actually gets a little bit more
complicated than i was originally
thinking
um rust can output a number of different
output options but
ultimately we're going to want to go
with static libraries
so as you might remember static
libraries are not compatible with k
build so we'll have to take some manual
steps
to actually make sure that this is going
to
properly work with cable
so this is a little bit more manual than
some people might like but it does work
consistently
and because static libraries really are
just
archived object files what we're going
to want to do is basically
unarchive that static library
and then with ld we can just link all of
those object files together
and we're going to get an object file
that actually gives us exactly what we
need
um this object file basically can then
just be passed directly off to cable
so now we're going to talk about some
rest specific gotchas so this is really
defined in kind of three different
levels so we're going to have the symbol
level
we'll have the foreign function
interface level and then we'll have
global state immutability
so at the symbol level we've already
kind of touched on no mangle so i'm not
going to go over that again but
we also need some build specific changes
for example
if you're doing this all manually then
you will have to make sure that your
code is compiled with some flags for
example to
put it in kernel address space and
basically use the procedural lookup
table instead of the global offset table
because of the nature of the kernel
address space
now all of this can kind of be avoided
and really has to be avoided because of
lib core
so when you're building normally with
cargo the
native build system then what it's going
to do is it's going to link in a
pre-compiled lib core
for you and when you do that then
essentially
you don't have any control over what
options that's actually been compiled
with
when you start linking it in your code
that you wrote might have the
appropriate flags for the compilation
however um libcore is not going to have
that
so really the only way that i found
around this is to use
x argo which is a cross compiler for
both your code
and libcore and then
thankfully they were nice enough to put
a linux kernel target
in that for us so this is going to be a
lot simpler
now at the ffi level we have a few
options
so we have bind gen um which is a tool
that can generate
bindings from c headers actually
but this is not really going to work for
us because bind gen doesn't actually
work with the kernel headers
now we can do diy bindings and some of
that is really necessary because
this is the only way to um
kernel methods directly from kernel
space
into our rest code this gets a little
bit messier because we actually have to
make sure that our data types match up
directly
between the kernel api and our api that
we've exposed
so this one should be done with caution
but it really is the only way
to expose kernel methods directly
we can also wrap kernel api calls in
kind of
safer c functions that have fewer
parameters
and this is actually really necessary
when we're doing things with
with the c preprocessor macros because
when we get into that area there's no
way to translate that across the ffi
boundary
so really this is going to be a large
part of what you end up having to do a
lot of the time
now definitely examine the trade-offs
carefully because
all of these um options have different
places and different kinds of ffi
and the rule of thumb that i would say
is if you're doing something with the c
preprocessor macros then essentially
or anything with structs even that have
if deaths in them
you'll want to offload that to c because
you may
you may want to try to win that war but
you will not
so this was kind of the most fun part
really what we're going to do here is
kind of say how can we get idiomatic
rust
outside of everything that we've built
on top of
so one option that i chose for
actually providing a safe interface to
global state mutation is that i actually
designed
um a mutex that kind of has a similar
pattern to the standard library
that actually wraps the kernel mutex
functionality
so it's going to really give us that
ability to kind of keep the rest
promises
um that the language requires
while also giving us a little bit more
idiomatic rest code
so here we're going to take a look
through some of this code
we essentially have our inner data type
and
so that's going to house our um data
that we're protecting
um we can actually immutably acquire a
mutex locks
so when we do that we're calling into c
which is going to call the kernel api
and then we get this mutex guard
returned
this mutex guard basically has a
lifetime that means as long as
it is in scope it will keep that lock
acquired
we can get a mutable reference from that
mutex guard
and then once it goes out of scope
that's what drop is for
then essentially it will unlock the
mutex and so
here what we're really getting is that
the mutex guard is basically going to
clean up after us
and so we really don't have to worry
about data races here
we're essentially guaranteed that rust
is going to clean up after us
and this is one of the major benefits of
the language
it's going to protect us against
programmer error
so in summary we can kind of um
take a few things away from this there
definitely are
going to be some additional challenges
um
using rust um and some c is definitely
still required
but rust's benefits really can be used
effectively in the kernel we can
kind of get a lot of things for free in
terms of resource management and clean
up
without really a performance hit um
and ultimately there was a whole lot
less unsafe than
i thought was initially going to be
required
so thank you for attending um here
is the link for um my source code if you
want to take a look through that and see
more
um if you want to see just sort of a
more in-depth example
of this thank you very much
any questions
so i've seen a couple other rust and
linux kernel
projects and i'm just curious how many
others you have looked at
and what you uh explored before you did
this
so i actually have i've looked at maybe
one
um when i started this project a while
ago i looked
around a little bit for this and i was
actually unable to find very many when i
started this
um i i'm not usually sure what the
approach they take is and the purpose of
this one was basically
instead of really getting down into the
weeds of
um exactly how we can do everything from
scratch
this really was intended to be how can
we make this as easy as possible and
that's ultimately why you did
this project
in the beginning you showed thermal file
and some console output and i saw that
you use rust
nightly does it mean that you cannot
build your coat with stable rust
so um x argo is going to require
nightly um because of the linux kernel
target you will require nightly for
now i'm not sure what the plans are for
stabilizing that
but right now it does require nightly
any more questions
well we'll wrap it up early there then
thank you all very much